now is the time where we have our goats
in a bad way draft peter king gets the
trivia question if he gets it right he
gets the first pick if he gets it wrong
sims gets the first pick either way i
will pick last peter eli manning started
last night for the first time since week
two eli manning is one of five players
to win multiple super bowl mvp awards
name three others
uh joe montana
tom brady and
uh
terry bradshaw
i mean that's just ridiculous absolutely
ridiculously easy absolutely ridiculous
the other one's bart starr yeah that's
pretty easy that's pretty easy jim
turner is not one of the choices in that
one i'm gonna save jim turner for a
later day all right uh peter you get the
first pick
i'm gonna give it to sam beale of the
new york giants you know this is one of
uh a very questionable picks by the
giants in recent years they used a third
round supplemental pick
uh
two summers ago or summer a year and a
half ago to take him so in other words
it cost them the 70th pick in the draft
this year which only could have been
guys like terry mclaurin of the redskins
and uh chase winovich of the patriots
but be that as it may
you know last night against the eagles
giants are up by seven they're about to
get off the field but no
on third down when the eagles do not
convert
sam beale is caught
illegal contact and so that gives the
giants
uh
or that gives the eagles a first down it
allows them to continue the drive and
then in overtime
twice he gets beat for uh completions on
the overtime drive it's just you know
he's
he's one guy on that defense and you
could have picked other guys on that
defense but give me sam beale for a flop
job at the end of the giants loss in
philly yeah well they certainly attacked
him there's no doubt about that um
and uh that giants defense is in
strugglesville as we know all together
all right you know what i'm i'm taking a
little different angle this one i'm
going with the referees in the patriots
chiefs game you know in a game where the
chiefs were
i thought just in my opinion after
watching the film and everything like
clearly the better team and had chances
at one point to really almost i mean the
game was 23-7 and they had the ball at
the middle of the field the kansas city
chiefs after saying all that
the new england patriots had chances to
win this football game and were screwed
over by the refs in that game and two
different points where it cost them 14
points i mean one of course we know the
travis kelsey fumble stefan gilmore is
picking that up looks like he's going to
run for a touchdown if he's not going to
run for a touchdown he's going to get
down there really close to the end zone
and at least put them in field goal
territory then of course
because of an earlier challenge in the
second half there is the nikhil harry
stepping out of bounds they call him out
of the three yard line he was not out of
bounds dives in for a touchdown to me
those are huge moments in that football
game that really cost new england who
wasn't necessarily the better team on
the field but in a typical new england
way hung around and had chances to win
that and we're screwed over by the refs
yeah i mean that's a huge point and a
good pick and you know what there needs
to be greater accountability for the
officials it drives me crazy when it
happens right in front of the guy as the
nikhil harry play did you're right there
and you don't see that guy's foot was
still fully within the green all right
for me this is the easiest goat pick i
will ever make this is a guy who self
goated himself chris bill o'brien the
head coach of the houston texans after
his team
was blown off the field by the denver
broncos for crying out loud o'brien said
i don't think there was anything very
good today i take full responsibility i
did not have this team ready to play i
thought i did but i thought wrong so
billy oh
you get the credit when you beat the
patriots you get the blame when your
team isn't ready to beat a broncos team
that really isn't playing for anything
at a time the texans were still playing
for everything bill o'brien is my first
pick in this week's goats in a bad way
draft peter you're up next
i wish i could have given it to jonah
munroe i should have made him my first
round pick that chris sims is very wily
the thing that really bothers me and
then i'll get to my goat is jonah monroe
who's the who's the official on the goal
line
called something that he did not see
right i think that is the worst thing
about officials he said that the guy's
foot was on the striper i thought that
the guy's foot was on the stripe it
never touched the strike you don't call
something you don't see
i wish i could give it to jonah monroe
but that chris sims he's on his game i'm
gonna give this i'm gonna give this uh
this goat pick to the carolina panthers
collectively to come out and lay a
gigantic egg
for perry fuel when perry fuel has been
trying most of his career to get a
legitimate head coaching sniff
and they come out and they give up 40 to
the atlanta falcons their offense does
nothing i'm giving it to the carolina
panthers for the no show in basically
jobbing perry fuel who's trying to get a
shot to be a head coach
yeah that was disappointing i you know
i'm mad at both you i wanted that
houston texans one and i was thinking
about going carolina there that was a
total yes lay of the egg there in the
atlanta falcons game completely by them
um man i'm going back to refereeville
here and i can't believe it this time
i'm going to 345 park ave and i'm going
to al riveron as into the jets miami
dolphins game at the end there the
game's gonna the game's going to be over
i mean the jets are in deep crap and
there is no past interference called on
the field and then of course it gets
thrown up to the booth in 345 park ave
where they review the play and then call
past interference now listen al
rivaran's been put in a very tough spot
i know that i get it but i just don't
like a play where when you watch it in
real time or watch it not only in real
time but watch the play in normal speed
it doesn't look like pass interference
and then we slow it down to ultra slow
motion and oh he got their uh hair
before the ball got there to me you know
what again and these big moments it's 45
seconds it's third and 17. you know
rubbing is right i mean are you kidding
me come on go are you kidding me you're
going to make a team lose that because
of that i mean i would have lost and
popped a gasket like brian flores did
too i mean i'm dead serious i might
actually got in a fight with the
referees after the game i mean i
understand how angry he was to me you
just don't call that rubbing is racing a
little contact is football and that was
just not enough to overturn or throw the
flag on a play where it had not been
thrown by the guys who were watching in
live action
hey and that b-roll of brian flores
going after the referee i wouldn't be
surprised if he gets fined i mean he was
up in his face dropping the f bomb that
that's something that is a no-no jason
garrett got fined of all people for that
earlier this year but uh the other thing
without river on yeah to add to your
point right in the pool report that came
out of that game where he explained why
he did what he did he actually said
that the standard for replay review for
past interference has not changed
throughout the course of the year
which
how how i don't know how you can utter
those words with a straight face right
and i understand there's a little
element that he's got to be baghdad bob
in this right that he's got a he's got
to spread the message um but but come on
there's a point where you just can't you
just can't you can't don't assume that
people are dumb because the average
football fan is smart enough to know
that the standard has changed throughout
the course of the year it's one of the
biggest issues that the nfl has been
dealing with all right for me next up uh
we i guess he's not a goat he's more of
a turkey because he went bowling on
saturday night did le'veon bell when he
had the flu and he was too sick to play
the next day instead of staying home he
goes out and he spotted reportedly this
has not yet been confirmed the jets
declined comment on the matter but
le'veon bell was spotted bowling from 10
30 p.m until 1am on saturday night while
his teammates were holed up in a hotel
somewhere getting ready to play the
dolphins the next day le'veon bell too
sick to play football not sick enough to
keep him from going bowling on a
saturday night
hey kudos to the new york post for
getting that story i just i read that
before we went on the air and i said
that's a good get
uh my last goat is going to be doug
marone
not only is this a 45 to 10
egg laying
against
the chargers on sunday at home
but
since
the fourth quarter since after the two
minute warning
in new england a couple of years ago in
the afc championship game
where the jacksonville jaguars were oh
so close to going to the super bowl a
stephon gilmore batted pass away that's
how close they were to going to the
super bowl
since that night the jacksonville
jaguars have played 29 games
they're 9 and 20.
how in the world do you go from the
heights of that moment
to being absolutely irrelevant for two
straight years
so you're gonna have to wear the goat
horns this morning doug marone yep uh i
damn i mean you stole my pick uh yes i'm
with you there i mean doug marone or the
the jags defense like what the hell
happened to them they let the chargers
have 9.1 yards per play in that game i
mean that's just unbelievable they have
fallen off the earth and i'm with you
there peter all the way all right for
lack of having a really a better pick
okay i i i feel like there's lack of
goats this week i'm going to go it's not
a great goat week it's not a great goat
week like there just wasn't a lot out
there i'm going to go even though i
think they are totally innocent as far
as the football side the video crew for
the new england patriots who went to the
cincinnati bengals game and you know put
the camera on this field or on the
sidelines for a little bit i mean i want
to just put it specifically on the video
crew not the new england patriots not
bill belichick he's got nothing to do
with it but also they got to have a clue
to who they're working for and the
stigma that's around them and to know
that hey you work for new england
everybody's gonna be watching you and
for you to put the camera on the field
like what a bunch of idiots and again i
don't think new england's football side
of this has any wrongdoing i've stated
that and i want to state it one more
time but uh that just to me is just i
just can't believe how stupid the video
crew is knowing hey we've been hired by
the new england patriots they have a
little bit of a history and here you are
wearing credentials and probably new
england gear and doing that you have to
be an idiot so they get to be a part of
the goat draft for that
all right and and for my last pick and
it's really not fair to single him out
because
it wasn't his decision and it wasn't his
fault that it happened but he's the one
in the highlight and that steelers
punter jordan berry who just got blown
up on the stupidest fake punt of the
year maybe ever up 10 deep in your own
end in the fourth quarter mike tomlin
called it the other 10 guys called it
off they all knew it was off but barry
is the guy who will always be seen
getting completely plastered because
he's the one who decided to take off
with the football and uh i'm sorry
jordan i'm sorry tad insult to injury
you get the goat horns for that hideous
and awful fake punt play all right
that's the goat draft for this week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports